moi je donne pas un euro à amazon je
commande rien sur amazon je suis un
vieux con et ce qu'ils font là bas je
commanderai même pas sur un mât zone ça
sert à rien commandé sur amazon nouvelle
a girl a maintenant la mort justement je
parle et vous parce que ce que vous
connaissez ce qu'il vit oui on les sait
ce qu'il dit c'est la mascotte de l'euro
2000 21 jours au sol et au saut
franchement elle éclate au sous sol elle
n'est pas du goût des fans du tout là
c'est la mascotte de l'euro qui baril et
donc ils s'appellent ce qu'ils y voient
les tories à mon avis ils se sont
inspirés d'un peu de cristiano ronaldo
j'ai l'impression qu'ils pensent qu'ils
sont extraits de raymond et de cristiano
ronaldo
non mais c'est vrai c'est raymond
ronaldo mais c'est qu'est-ce qui se
marrent comment on peut payer des
centaines de milliers d'euros pour
parrainer un truc comme ça ils ont l'air
d'une mascotte
nan mais c'est de faire un truc original
qui marque visuellement comme sous 680
juste une affaire a failli avec ses
fauteuils qui ressemblait à isabelle est
plutôt regarder les footix regard des
footix
merci bâti comme une sympathique
il y avait une super victoire aussi dans
l'euro 2016 il raté aussi way regardez
ouais
[Rires]
mais si les ig ont raté là ils ont ils
ont raté raté qu'un seul aime bien
j'adore je n'ai moi on est sensible à ça
j'ai déjà dit les jaunes et moi c'est
non sa section la phrase quand elle
démarre comme ça vous fait quoi les jeux
horrible c'est un peu free style un peu
manga peu film d'animation c'est un truc
pour jeunes voient la vie en main
comprend pas ça franchement ça merde
hein quoi franchement c'est la merde
hein c'est affreux moyens au niveau des
analystes
[Applaudissements]
montrez pas big band analyse thaï ha
merde
le dire c'est de la merde ceni la c zéro
on n'est pas plus mal a fait sien c'est
que la couleur ne va pas le mec n'a pas
de couvre le mec n'a pas témoigné il a
pas de cheville il a une tête
insupportables ça va pas du tout on
dirait que les salles moi je le trouve
ça on dirait il allait il a des blessés
en fait je sais que c'est pas vrai gars
cas voilà c'est la mascotte de l'euro
l'avez vous et bien voici je parlais à
gilles je lui dirai que moi je suis
d'accord avec lui m'attendrit d'accord
dans les menus de footix mois ce qui
paraît malades très bien écouter en
vacances mais c'est aussi une défaite
beaucoup chiot